Jacob Zuma
Aww..
Have you heard of this guy? Does this face ring a bell?
What if I say his name is Jacob Gedleyihlekisa Zuma? Now, do you understand?
Well, this man is the former president of South Africa and here you can find him breaking it down
A quirky figure you might say. Well Zuma has all kinds of history history that involves accepting bribes
corruption, fraud, racketeering
You know
Ah just just one of those
It doesn't matter. If there's one thing for certain about Jacob Zuma and that's one thing.
Numbers is Jacob Zuma's number one enemy.
Okay. Let's watch one of my favorite clips of Jacob Zuma.
One of many
We announce that our membership figures
stood at
Seven hundred and sixty nine. Eight hundred ten
Seven hundred. Listen properly. hundred and sixty nine
thousand
eight hundred and
twenty
Was that it
at the end of the and
seventh and
Seventeen. Thank you
You know without the seventy, Indiana
I would really have thought he didn't know what the hell he was talking about seemed we can follow that
Let's just see if we can what should I use in text on stood yet?
as I've been hundred and sixty nine seventy six and eight hundred and
You mean six one six nine million eight hundred seven hundred I am
Say another nine and sixty nine
certain
2820 oh
I see. Okay, so he started he started over here. It still doesn't match and 7th and
seventy members down from
100 I come on cut him some slack. All right. Why should he know how to handle numbers?
It's not like he stopped rising at oh
My god, you think America was dealt a bad hand
Okay think of South Africa, but he's so funny and quirky he does dancing but wait there is more
Oh god, there's so many more
Oh
This guy just keeps grabbing numbers from everywhere whatever you think he's done he decides another thousand another million it doesn't matter
Come on, you know it's not like a five-year-old could do this better?
Is key
Hahahaha
The number of babies shall be positive was reduced
By sixes percent from twenty four thousand two thousand eight two eight
four two eight
point two
two to eight hundred
Point twenty
The numbers Jacob, what do they mean?
Eight point two to eight point two hundred the numbers dropped from twenty four thousand
To eight point two to eight point two hundred if anyone knows what that means. Let me know
I really like these news clips because they have a translator and they just don't know how to translate his ineptitude
Megawatts
This guy is talking about nope
You know, it's no coincidence that they're Doomsday Clock is what how close is it it's two minutes
That's fine. Doesn't matter. Maybe just maybe we need to be more careful with who we vote for in our democracies
Wow, where did he get that number?
That's a great statistics vicaroo by two hundred and three thousand apples I think
It couldn't handle figure between seven to eight hundred this continent is the Asian continent
in the world
Not separated even by a river
The rivers that are there flow with the continent they don't cut it
How can you have a Potter?
All continents put together will fit in into Africa. Oh wow
Fun fact fun fact time all the continents fit into Africa, you know, he's not wrong
He's not just the master of numbers
He's also a master of the fun facts all continents fit into Africa as you can tell here
this is one of those illusions where it
Like it wouldn't work
But if you try it
You can see it clearly
like USA has so much space North America has so much space left in Africa and if you take
Europe there's
Plenty of space from Europe as well if you cut it out it. Yes
You can tell here it all fits into Africa. All right, this guy is a president over country
Jesus Christ, how are we alive?
How one video he is literally the scene from washing powers
$1,000,000,000. It's literally the living embodiment and the Zulu Zulu
I don't know. What a billion is in similar some buffoon. This was none season. Is that true?
Is that the actual translation that can't be right, but you might not believe but it's money that can't run away
run away
Billions has been stolen from governments. Okay, this is very concerning
Now apparently Zuma has had such an impact that other people are affected by this
There's a conspiracy going on called the Zuma virus that makes people not able to number look at the translator here
But my favorite one is this one I don't know if this is even real problem or a problem rising
Rupee red pepper deep
problema popping crab open up Oh peep
Peep you can tell how done the translator ladies. She's a lady
Professionals been financially all professionals
I'll give you one thing though
He has a contagious laugh and I think he knows thank you very much if I can laugh because I would always laugh
Answer to answer you sure not stalling
Thank You
Mr. President, it appears that you are very well advised by your Minister of Health because medical experts say that if you want to live
A long and healthy life. Then you laugh everyday?
Life I ever heard
You know some people
Who could not pronounce cancer they've now led
Konza
Con song this is guy actually roasting people how they can articulate Jesus Christ cons
I
Really miss him he used to steal so much money from our tax papers. He's one of the clever ones
He might be stupid, but he still managed to take a lot of sa money Jesus Christ, dude
Apparently God lately Casa means one who smiles while causing you harm. Well, isn't that ironic?
Julian onziema. Thank you for coming in. Thank you. Good morning here Zoomers, brother d
You ugly I'm not sexually active right now
So, what did I enjoy this lately choice by choice me I've just not I've chosen not to engage
Doesn't that make you gay?
Why doesn't that make me gay I am I am ill and attracted to a female
So who is gay oh
God I shouldn't laugh. It's a sad. Oh well, good morning
Why are you gay straight to the point some male and attracted to form a so whose Oh God
alright, well, that's all you need to know about Jacob Zuma if you enjoyed this video smash like
Subscribe, we got a hit a hundred million
Come on bros
Since I still have you make sure to check out epic merge represent coms - PewDiePie
Support the channel and I see you guys tomorrow what you never play - birthday maleta, you know
It's fun, right? I'm not supposed to give my opinion
But give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not not convinced yet. Okay. I'll cut you a deal
The game is available for free and that's a great price